We now know how to get from RGB to YUV,
so
you can actually do some cool
things with that, all right?
Let's plot the pixels that we're
looking at before instead of
RGB space into YUV space, okay?
Well here, you see a YUV distribution,
all right?
And looking at it just like this,
it's, it's not clear yet
that we've bought a lot of improvement.
But supposed we ignored the y value,
right?
We just projected everything
down onto the UV plane.
What would this distribution look like?
Well, it would look like this, okay?
And suddenly, it's a lot easier to see
how you would separate out the different
pixels of different colors.
In fact, we can try filtering
on just this UV dimension